i truly believe that the culture at the
low heart is uh is very unique uh we are
all mission driven i mean uh most of the
people that join aloha join it for a
personal reason or for a passion to this
fielder to do good
to the world so we have a mission and we
we work together
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is with mikhail goodman the cto
and cso at hello heart a healthcare
startup that helps patients track
understand and improve their chronic
conditions
before joining hello heart michal worked
as r d manager at trusteer an israeli
cyber security company acquired by ibm
for nearly a billion dollars
michal has over 15 years of software
development and research experience
which enabled her to lead along with her
colleagues the largest peer-reviewed
research on digital health that was
conducted by the company michael holds a
bs in computer science and biology with
an emphasis on bioinformatics before
that served in the elite unit 8200
making such a huge positive impact using
technology
literally the reason why i entered tech
in the first place you know
understanding how to use deep technology
to work with consumer behavior to to
make a positive impact here in the
health space your engineering background
spends well beyond health and into other
verticals as well and and as a leader
i'm i'm excited to hear a little bit
from you how you've seen your own
personal development and and how you
bring those experiences today to the the
incredible mission that hello heart is
on a fantastic company post series c
company with some incredible investors
on board resolute and coachline and some
amazing amazing partners with you and so
um i can only imagine what it's like to
be on this rocket ship and at the same
time saying the the awesome ways in
which you're helping people take control
over
their or over their their ability to
manage their diseases and so mikhail
tell me a little bit about yourself and
and you know a little bit about your
journey
sure
uh i was born in a
recent here in israel
and as a younger sister to two older
brothers i grew up to like video games
more than any other game
because i wanted to play with them
and basically i wrote my first video
game at the age of 14. it was tetris in
a visual basic
and my first website at the age of 16
which was a way to communicate with my
girlfriend imagine a time before what's
up facebook and stuff
so technology was always a part of my
journey part of my my life
after that i served in the elite unit
age 200.
when i completed
my service i started my bachelor's
degrees in computer science and biology
with the emphasize on bioinformatics
basically i yeah i already i
always had a passion to computer science
but i always also have a passion to
biology
and um and the medical field in general
had small dream to become a doctor but i
killed it
back then
so when i found out about this degree
which was relatively new at the time i
understood that this is uh
this is the perfect fit for me
after i graduated i
spent several years in the cyberspace
field
which was amazing experience
working in cyber security every day you
have a new challenge and the amount of
data you're working with is crazy
and
every day you need to solve some problem
but you need to solve it yesterday
and one of the startup i worked with was
a trustee that was also acquired by uh
by ibf by ibm sorry
uh but
but after like more than 10 years um i
decided to
search and see if i can find the
companies that will combine
biomed and uh technology and then i
found uh hello hearts and i'm enjoying
the ride ever since
so walk me through the inflection point
of
joining hello heart first on on a
personal level so you know you're
mentioning the search
and you're looking for what else to do
you've already seen
success numerous times throughout your
career whether it be in academia or in
startups or in the idf
really meaningful positions and
meaningful verticals what was that
search for really
so
it was a very
particular search i knew exactly what i
wanted
i didn't search for any title i search
for a company that will work in
in the biomed field if it's healthcare
or
genetic or something about that and back
then in israel
the numbers of companies and that and so
that was not a lab
and i also search for a small company
where i can really influence and make an
impact and feel like i contribute to the
company's success
and actually a friend of mine introduced
me to hello hearts and
and they were like super small 10 people
back then they didn't have even have
like
um career page in their website
so i found the co-founders dave meltzer
on linkedin and i found his personal
email address actually oh and i just
sent him a message yeah
like hey
your company sounds super interesting
let's meet
wow yeah and they agree
so so what about the company that point
really drew you in because that's quite
quite unique because i'm sure that with
your expertise and your experience you
had a lot of people knocking on your
door at that point to come and and you
know join their journeys yet you send
you send a message what what prompted
you to do that
um
i
read and i checked my network about
mayan coin which is the ceo and steve
meltzer and their experience really
resonates and
and
when i met them i
completely
was
amazed by
by the product they built by the company
they built the culture they have at the
low heart and i really
believe that they can take this company
further
and again we were like 10 people now we
are 130.
so i hope i made the right decision but
it looks like i did that definitely did
tell me a little bit about the pain
point of hello heart and the
you know the solution that you're
bringing
both from a technological perspective
but also from a consumer shift in
consumer behavior perspective
yeah
so before we explain about the people
and that we have at hello heart uh and
in the journey that we had uh
a bit about the love hearts uh so
basically our mission is to empower
patients to understand and improve their
heart health using technology
today the average person use
his cell phone about five hours a day if
not even more so uh
what we want is that we want to leverage
that in to actually saves life so we
started with the hypertension which is
the lead cause death in the us and heart
conditions in the world in general and
now we're expanding to improve leukemia
and also to erythria
um
basically what we are doing is we have a
mobile device that comes with a blood
pressure cuff wireless part pressure
cuff the cuff measure the user is able
to measure his vitals using the cuff the
cuff sends
the results to the to the mobile app and
now the magic
begins and we start with the simplest
things which is to actually explain the
user what the numbers even mean you will
be surprised how many usual does not
know what is the big number or the small
number or
or is it good is it bad uh where should
they aim to
so we start with that so you're saying
by the way you're saying and i'll touch
on this later on a little bit again
because you're mentioning this is the
simple thing but i think you know like
you're mentioning it's not that simple
and also from a company perspective yeah
being able to do it well that that is
probably the hardest part of this whole
thing right
yes uh this is true it's not really uh
it's not really simple because you need
to build the trust and you need to make
the user believe in your device and
those devices are pretty new they're in
the world for like 10 years
and
most people
prior to covet wanted to see their
doctor they don't want the app the
mobile app or even or technology in
general to to explain to them what they
have
so uh we needed to spend a lot on making
sure that the user experience is flow us
and that we explain to the user that
this product actually works and we are
and we have uh
accuracy the same as you will have in
the doctor office
and of course of course the privacy when
you are working with the medical data
and especially when for us because we
are working in a b2b2c model which means
which is business to business to
consumer which means and we sell our
solutions to uh in our case to employer
in the u.s market and the employers give
the solution to their employees so the
privacy is super important and
many
many of our users
want to make sure that their data will
not be shared with their employer that
it will not impact their
their health status their health
insurance
uh so yeah now it sounds simple but we
had uh quite a quite of a ride and to
make sure that our users will feel uh
comfortable measuring their blood
pressure at their home so what are the
you know the challenges that are being
presented when you're working on a b to
b to c company where trust is such an
important figure here you know the brand
and the recognition that people feel
safe and secure with with with both
using
and understanding and agreeing with the
product how do you what are the biggest
challenges this presents
basically now
um i would say that our company is
divided into two we have the b2b part
and we have to be to sip the b2c part uh
because
in one in one
for our customer success for our go to
market team their client is the employer
but for our product design
uh user marketing their client is the
end user so basically we have
two marketing departments one depart one
marketing department that aim for the
end user but one marketing departments
that end for the clients
so it's a it's a big of a challenge and
it's also a challenge because in some
places the
the
the business the clients the ones that
pays they want you to do something they
want uh to influence the roadmap so they
have some kind of idea but
the user will not actually want it you
know that they will not use it or it
will not help the users improve their
portal so why should they do it so it's
like a bottle and you need to decide
which one to take um
and also the sharing of data it's also
an issue because
the
the business like the clients they want
the data they want that just to get all
the information that they can uh but we
always
we build our products from the patient
side not from the medical side so we are
here for the users our users come first
and this is something that we will never
do we will never share data
even if it will cost us some clients
right and so with technology being at
the forefront here what is technology
really enabled
you both as you as a leader but as an
organization to do that wasn't available
you know even 10 years ago
uh i will give you an example of one of
our latest uh features that we launched
last year which is a
irregular heart detection
basically now we can detect the regular
heart which is uh it's it's a very uh
complex condition that you cannot detect
all the time it's not something that you
have 24 hours
and so if you will go to the doctor to
check that it's not necessarily means
that at the right moment that you you
will see at the doctor office you will
have this uh irregular heartbeat
but when you can measure it every time
when you are at home so for example if
you feel fatigue or dizziness and you
have your device near you so you will be
uh more able to catch
those events and it's a life-threaten
event so this is basically what we did
using technology uh to be able to
measure the heart rate and to find like
a best line baseline into um to see
abnormality in your heart rates and
according to that to detect irregular
heartbeats
incredible and so if you're looking at
technology as an enabler here you know
moving forward and where you know even
in general with with the medical space
and and the way that customers are able
to
interact with their illnesses in a in a
different way
what how do you see this advancing how
do you see you know the new technologies
that are being developed now
specifically you know with machine
learning and and our ability to really
make sense of lots of data how is that
going to change the consumer behavior in
the health space
wow the technology is involving all the
time and it's crazy uh what we have now
is the wearable devices it's amazing you
get so many
uh data points on you how you sleep how
you snore
um how you walk if you will fall
it's
your
your oxygen level your temperature level
and so using all of that i really
believe that
we can um first of all uh reduce
unnecessary uh medical intervention like
surgery but even medication
and the fact that
in for example in the united states many
users are suffering from overdoses of
medication because
no one was um
because no one really take the time to
give the specific doses or maybe after
like four months of using this uh
medication for a chronic disease we can
change
the the prescription i mean it can
happen so using something that will
monitor you all almost all the time will
help us solve that and now we can
actually see that
people are being more engaged people
have the trust now and technology people
understand now that they don't need to
go to the medical
office uh although aloha does not intend
to uh
to to be instead of the medical uh of
the doctor uh we just
want to a to tell the user when is the
right time for him to actually seek a
medical condition
a medical assistant
how is this journey different for you
now so you've done the searching and you
reached out to this company you're more
than 130 people now after you were 10
people
been with us since its growth well how
do you see
your journey different here than before
uh
being at a low heart
from a 10
people company to 130 and counting we
are growing all the time
it's a credible journey my role has
changed
every six months
the
the task or the job responsibility i had
when i started and the the ones that i
have today is completely different your
job all the time involving and changing
and the people that you work with all
the time changing and so it's crazy to
be part of a hyper growth startup it's
it's something that uh
i
you need to try it i
really recommend it to everyone to try
to be part of startup would do you see
yourself going back to
the previous verticals that you used to
interact with you know look at this a
cyber security space or traditional b2b
says is that something that you see
yourself doing again
post hola hard or has this experience
changed a little bit your ambitions
within
your career or the tech space
yeah
so this experience changed a lot how i
see
using technology when i first
in my first month at the low heart i
couldn't really understand the
difference of blue color like
i mean one shade of blue was the same
shades for me
the user experience was not something
that i thought it's so
crazy and so important
uh but now i understand that it is it
can actually make a product successful
or to fail
so um i think that i all i will always
want to be in to work on a product that
uh
that put emphasize on the user
experience and to it to continue to
research user behavioral and
to use that to create even
even better products
so to go back to
to cyber security there
i
i think i will stay with the
medical space
the
today you know everybody's talking about
culture and the vibe and uh
you know making a positive impact
what is the feeling within hello heart
you know is there is there a feeling of
of mission driven of you know people
working towards a greater goal is there
a sense of that
of that culture there
yeah um
i truly believe that the culture at the
low heart is is very unique uh
we are
all mission driven i mean uh most of the
people that join our heart join it for a
personal reason or for a passion to this
field or to do good uh to the world so
we have a mission and we we work
together um beside that our culture is a
is a very open to feedback which is
something that
i didn't find in every place that i
worked with
we think that feedback is a necessity
and not and nice to have
uh
we make a decision based on data and not
based on seniority or titles
so
basically the company really uh listen
to
uh to the employees and not just telling
them
what to do and i think that in this uh
culture the employees at a low heart
feel like they can speak their mind
share ideas and and contribute to the
success of the lower heart
and
it translates to
to be an environment where people really
enjoy
coming to the office uh which in those
days it's not something very common i
agree
mikhail this is so awesome and i'm so
inspired by your work with hello heart
you have incredible partners and
incredible
people that are making such a positive
impact and uh and like i mentioned in
the start this is you know the reason
why i got into technology myself is to
find those interests points of
intersection
where you have a challenge of a con
consumer challenge
that through behavior that we can alter
we can improve the lives dramatically
and we can provide more information in
it but in a different way and it's just
exciting so can't wait to see what's
happening with hello heart and thank you
very much for joining and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you
[Music]
you